sí
[Música]
este es un drone comercial clásico pero
tiene algo especial contiene granadas de
40 milímetros modificadas para que
exploten cuando alcancen su objetivo
drones como éste son utilizados por los
militares ucranianos y están equipados
con explosivos pero también son los ojos
de los militares en el cielo para tratar
de conseguir la caída de las tropas
rusas marcan xian ex marine y experto en
seguridad del centro de estudios
estratégicos e internacionales
los drones comerciales son drones que se
pueden comprar en un almacén al que
pueden ir cualquier ciudadano pero los
drones militares se producen para el
ejército
una gran diferencia entre ambos es que
los drones militares son más resistentes
están diseñados para un uso repetido
están construidos para funcionar en
muchos muchos tipos de entornos
diferentes
un ejército que no tiene acceso a drones
militares normales compraría y
utilizaría drones comerciales la gente
es muy inteligente y muy ingeniosa y los
convierte en armas útiles
ayuso ones
uno puede comprar muchos y considerar
los artículos desechables que se usan
una o dos veces y eso es todo el
personal militar ucraniano puede
simplemente ir a los almacenes y pedir
drones comerciales sospecho que muchos
lo hacen a un equipo fuerte gente tras
el inicio de la invasión rusa en el mes
de febrero el gobierno ucraniano pidió
que se les donarán drones como resultado
se reunieron unos 6000 estos drones
pueden ser modificados para llevar
pequeñas armas cuando se lanzan desde el
aire pueden causar daños significativos
en las partes vulnerables de los tanques
y vehículos blindados rusos si
a veces se ven drones con pequeños
explosivos adheridos que las tropas
ucranianas lanzan sobre las fuerzas
enemigas tal vez con granadas de mano o
algo así
[Música]
también pueden ser utilizados para
grabar los drones comerciales disponen
de sistemas de vídeo que pueden ser
útiles para ver dónde se encuentran las
fuerzas enemigas y quizás ayudar en los
ataques de artillería
strikes
o si vemos otros drones que pueden ser
utilizados como kamikazes es decir que
encuentran a un soldado enemigo y vuelan
hacia él para herirlo
ventaja estás en el aire
y tú
no hay duda de que estos drones son algo
bueno para el ánimo de las tropas está
claro que los soldados implicados están
muy orgullosos de lo que hacen
y
es probable que esto haga que los rusos
sean un poco más cautelosos y es posible
que caminen mirando hacia arriba
preguntándose si hay un dron volando
hacia ellos
[Música]
este hombre señala una obra de arte
instalada durante la marcha del orgullo
gay de beirut mientras otorga destruyen
ambos pertenecen a un grupo cristiano
extremista llamado los soldados del
señor desde 2019 han atacado activistas
y símbolos lgp llevando a cabo
intimidaciones y también oponiéndose a
la legalización del matrimonio civil en
el líbano row la tan no especialista en
fundamentalismo religioso no se explica
si hablamos de las características que
definen a este grupo su fanatismo
religioso se esgrime como una especie de
defensa
estas personas se creen los abogados de
dios están convencidos de tener razón
están en la defensiva porque creen que
son perseguidos cuando no es así
la novia
de
alé
[Música]
su reacción es violenta porque se dan
cuenta de que no son aceptados por la
sociedad que es moderada rechaza sus
ideas fundamentalistas y pretenden
volver a los orígenes de la religión
pero en realidad se trata de una cultura
religiosa de un tiempo pasado cuanto más
los rechaza la sociedad más extremista
se vuelve en líbano es un país
multiconfesional en donde las religiones
pesan mucho sólo se permite el
matrimonio religioso y la legalización
del matrimonio civil es un tema de
debate habitual el grupo de soldados del
señor al igual que la mayoría de las
figuras religiosas libanesas se opone
categóricamente porque en su opinión
está abriría un camino para las uniones
entre personas del mismo sexo en los
países árabes especialmente en las
sociedades multiconfesionales los
líderes religiosos tienen un gran
control sobre los aspectos civiles de la
vida la herencia el matrimonio o el
divorcio por lo tanto la estructura
social está estrechamente vinculada a la
estructura religiosa que a su vez dicta
la estructura política libanesa la
propuesta de ley de matrimonio civil se
enfrenta a un gran rechazo por que
despojaría a las personas de su
filiación religiosa tanto
en el 2002
maneras latín de la más distinta
estos soldados del señor no sólo se
oponen a los homosexuales o al
matrimonio civil sino que se consideran
defensores de los principios de dios en
nombre de la iglesia
este es el final del primer episodio de
los observadores de esta temporada todos
nuestros contactos recuerden están
siempre en nuestra pantalla para que nos
envíen sus imágenes hasta pronto